So one of the other important things to notice about this
pairing that we see after lining the chromosomes up, is that
we have two copies, because we get one from Mom and
one from Dad. So if we look in each pair here, one
of the copies of this pair of chromosomes came from Mom
and one came from Dad. And the same is true for the
next pair, and the next pair, and the next pair, right
on down the line. Obviously at this point it's important for us
to have some kind of naming system so
we know which chromosome is which. We actually number
the chromosomes in order from biggest to smallest. So
that the biggest chromosome pair, they're both called chromosome
one. And then chromosome two, chromosome three, four,
five, and six, and right on down the line.
So in this case, if I say" Hey, let's
look somewhere at chromosome 13," I know immediately that
I'm interested in that pair right there. Or, if
I'm interested in chromosome, let's say eight. I know
to look right there. But there's actually something missing
right here. And I don't know if you noticed it
yet, but look really closely, something is not right
about our line up. So what's wrong with this picture
here, take a look and see if you can
figure out what it is, and then type whatever answer
you think it is into the text box.
I'll give you one hint There's something missing. So
see if you can figure out what it is and write it in this text box here.